hello
uh
oh so sorry
cool it
surrender and i'll be gentle
huh
is this an answer from this world
it's a storm barrier
it looks so dangerous
leave it to me
although this wooden liar is all i have
i don't need the liar to break through
this kind of storm bait
wait
what is that
enemy attack prepare yourselves
the stage will need to be cleared before
i can begin my performance
generally speaking such chores are not
the concerns of the performer himself
wait
what's going on
there shouldn't be any hilly trail camps
in the vicinity of storm terror's lair
oh
[Music]
let it rain
[Music]
the hilly trolls usually do not venture
into areas with high elemental
concentrations
it puts a heavy burden on their bodies
the abyss order must be manipulating
them behind the scenes yet they
shouldn't have been able to determine
that we would come
and presumably spreading their forces to
halt our plans
without further ado
i suppose i can play faster if my only
audience is the wind
[Music]
it actually opened you're not entirely
useless toned fart
this is it we are now entering storm
terror's lair
watch yourselves let's move
[Music]